INJURIES, THEY'V THE
LOOKS TO BE OKAY BUT GOING TO
HEAD TO ZADINA.
TRICK AGAINST TORONTO AND THEN
EE
THE STICK, BOY, YOU GET IT TOO
LATE I IK, A
GOOD TAKEOUT.
SLOT SHOT, SAVE BY NEDELIJKOVIC
OFFEAL
FOR SURE AND ZADINA IN TO
ANSWER, A SHOT MISSING, LARKIN,W
GLOVESIDE O BACK.
TOFFOLI, GOING BACK THAT
HAVE ALLEN LEAVE THE GAME HE HAN
THE LAST WAS THE
RIGHT CALL BECAUSE SHOOT THE
PUCK, NO MATTER WHERE YOU ARE.
LARKIN ALMOST ONWAS FABBRI,
WITH A BLIND PASASHTD THAT TIMEY
ARMIA AND THEN IT IS TO GET IT
AND THEN ON THE AND THEN
OVERTOP OF THE LUCAS RAYMOND
GOING TWO
KENNY?
KEN: THAT I AM.
NOT HARD TO VISUALIZE THAT HE
COULD BE ON THE BLUEND, OH,
ONE ON THE
AT RED WINGS.COM. WELL, GALLAGHA
.
AND SO? IS LARKIN,